Just take a few tips from people like Thomas C. Corley...
...who has studied tons of self-made millionaires.
They read every day and not celebrity gossip.
Think biographies, self-help, and history books.
Corley says 88% of ridiculously rich people...
...spend at least 30 minutes a day reading to gain knowledge.
They mingle with other rich people...
...and cut out toxic people from their lives.
They also keep in touch with people even when they don't need them...
...for a new job, for instance.
They constantly wish people happy birthday,...
...call to say hi and volunteer.
The rich keep getting richer...
...because they know where to funnel their money.
Corley says most millionaires he studied...
...seemed to have three sources of income.
For most of them, real estate rentals, stock market investments,...
...and owning a side business.